c'est ici que commence notre périple car
toute la semaine on vous fait découvrir
les véloroutes de la région et
aujourd'hui on commence par la vélocenie
450 km entre Paris et le Mont
Saint-Michel et ça tombe bien elle passe
par une partie de l'Eure-et-Loir nous on
se dirige vers meslay-le-grenais une
petite commune avec une église assez
particulière suivez-moi
[Musique]
une petite porte là c'est dur
[Applaudissements]
bonjour vous êtes anchevés
devant l'église de mêlé le Grenay
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'elle a de
particulier cette église il faut rentrer
à l'intérieur pour découvrir pourquoi
elle a quelque chose de particulier
une des premières choses que je vois que
j'observe en entrant dans l'église c'est
toutes ces peintures murales il me
semble pas avoir déjà vu ça dans
d'autres églises ou d'autres lieux de
culte ce qu'on appelle une danse macabre
et c'est quoi une danse macabre c'est
vraiment la ronde de la vie avec des
squelettes on les voit alternés et puis
entre chacun de ces squelettes des
personnages quand on regarde bien on
aperçoit un petit bébé dans un berceau à
côté de lui un personnage squelettique
qui est doté d'une faux et puis plus on
va avancer plus on va à la fois
parcourir les âges de la vie alors on
voit apparaître notamment donc des
adultes mais qui appartiennent toujours
à la société civile et puis
progressivement aussi les hommes
d'église et on va passer de l'abbé par
l'évêque pour arriver vous le voyez
aussi par le chevalier et puis
effectivement donc et bien chlore en
quelque sorte ceci par la présence du
pape quel que soit la situation que l'on
est occupé dans cette vie terrestre pour
la vie céleste ensuite tout le monde
sera en quelque sorte ici
évidemment donc juger de la même manière
Anne on va faire une courte pause pour
se rendre à Arsys c'est près de
Nogent-le-Rotrou on va aller voir l'un
des nombreux gîtes qui se trouve sur la
vélocenie le Manoir Du Bois Joli c'est
un lieu qui vaut le détour regardez
bienvenue au bois et jolie lorsque
Julien bélier nous ouvre ses portes nous
sommes transportés dans une autre époque
devant nous une ancienne bâtie
senioriale du 16e siècle Julien qui a
passé toute sa jeunesse a décidé de tout
plaquer pour y ouvrir un git en 2017
parce que pour moi des bâtisses comme
ici c'est des lieux chargés d'histoire
c'est des centaines de personnes qui ont
travaillé qui ont vécu ici et pour moi
on est vraiment dans un lieu d'histoire
collective qui est important de faire
partager
les lieux ont été rachetés par ses
parents dans les années 80 la plupart
des bâtiments étaient en ruine tu te
rappelles j'étais monté pour voir
l'état de la charpente etc il a fallu
une trentaine d'années pour tout
restaurer c'est tout d'abord une
histoire de couple qui avions le même
projet ça c'est une évidence et après
une histoire de famille c'est évident
aussi puisqu'on voit maintenant Julien
qui est impliqué dans les hébergements
donc c'est vrai que c'est une histoire
de famille
et le travail n'est pas terminé Julien
et son père Victor veulent désormais
s'attaquer à la restauration du porche
l'ancienne entrée principale du bâtiment
la vue d'ensemble
la vie c'est ça c'est l'aventure c'est
ce jeter à l'eau aujourd'hui le gîte
dispose de 8 couchages dans le bâtiment
historique auquel s'ajoutent ces trois
roulottes entièrement rénovées
celle-ci est de style Art déco
des années 30 qui a vraiment gardé voilà
avec les carreaux biseautés au niveau
des fenêtres avec les miroirs biseauté
avec toutes les boiseries un lieu chargé
d'histoire au cœur de la campagne
Percheron l'occasion de faire une pause
le temps d'une nuit avant de reprendre
la route
[Musique]
Anne on est à allier-combray on est au
jardin du Pré Catelan c'est quoi
exactement le jardin du Pré Catelan on
est directement dans l'atmosphère dans
la vie de ce qui était la constitution
du roman de Marcel Proust à la recherche
du temps perdu puisque c'est à la fois
un lieu qui l'a connu qui a été aménagé
chez par son oncle paternel et en même
temps qui était une source d'inspiration
pour son roman enfin et il évoque les
plaisirs qu'il avait ici à se promener
dans ce beau jardin dans ton profite
maintenant parce qu'en fait c'est devenu
un jardin public
et Marcel Proust en vérité la famille
donc du côté du père de Marcel Proust
était très attaché à ce bourg puisqu'ils
sont installés là depuis des siècles et
on sait qu'il venait donc régulièrement
avec sa mère et son frère puisque Marcel
Proust avait un jeune frère mais ceci
plutôt pendant les premières années de
l'enfance de Marcel Proust peut-être
qu'il arrêtera d'ailleurs de venir
précisément parce que et bien ce
trop-plein de nature pour lui qui va
être particulièrement asthmatique pose
un problème
merci beaucoup Anne la vélocenie c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui demain on reprend
la route pour le Cher à vélo un tout
nouvel itinéraire entre Tours et
Montluçon alors à demain